today is the first day of the Supreme
Court's new term the justices are set to
take on a series of controversial topics
chief legal correspondent Jim Crawford
is at the Supreme Court Jan what are the
big issues that courts are going to
address this term well I mean Anthony
this is shaping out to be one of the
most contentious Supreme Court turns in
years and they are taking up almost
every hot-button issue that's out there
you've got abortion gay rights gun
rights immigration and they're going to
jump right into it starting tomorrow
with a big case that looks at whether
federal law protects gays lesbians
transgender people from discrimination
on the job and then in the months to
come they're gonna look at whether or
not States can put more regulations on
abortion clinics whether States I can
make it more difficult for legal gun
owners to take their guns outside their
homes they're going to look at president
Trump's efforts to end that Obama era
program that protects the so-called
dreamers those people that came to the
United States illegally as children all
of these cases and they're probably
going to be decided right in the middle
of this election year early spring early
summer Jan you mentioned gay rights that
this is the first time the courts gonna
hear gay right
gay rights cases since the retirement of
Justice Kennedy who was the swing vote
on this issue so so who are you going to
be looking at on the court at this point
well I mean this is a different court it
could potentially be a more conservative
court and we'll get a lot of clues this
term because of the line of these cases
like you said justice brick Cavanaugh
replacing Justice Kennedy Justice
Kennedy was a conservative but he would
sometimes vote with liberals on some of
those social issues particularly gay
rights but also abortion so the question
is is justice Cavanaugh going to see
those cases in a more conservative way
that would shift the balance of the
court more to the right on some of these
social issues the Chief Justice John
Roberts also someone that we're going to
be looking at because sometimes he's
been willing to vote with the Liberals
on some of those a big controversial
cases like for example Obamacare so will
he moved from that conservative camp I
mean obviously it's still five to four
you've got the five conservatives and
the four liberals but some of these
cases they'll go back and forth this
term will give us a lot of clues about
what this court is going to look like
going forward Jan Crawford at the
Supreme Court thanks Jan